a conductor is like a director in the
sense that a conductor sets the scene
that allows the actors the musicians to
step fully into the music my name is
Kent Riedel I'm a conductor and an
organist I live in New York City
[Music]
protecting is kind of mysterious and not
so mysterious these beat patterns anyone
can learn and they're in textbooks as
are the concept of m'god
[Music]
[Applause]
articulations this is all in the
textbooks
a conductor needs to be able to do a
number of things very very well you have
to have a clear beat pattern and that
has to be modified for whatever the
musical context is the conductor needs
to have a sense of tempo and one of the
hardest parts of maintaining or
developing a sense of timing is that
when the Adrenaline's on and you're in
front of an audience and performers your
sense of time can change
[Music]
communication is a very big part of what
the conductor needs to do
there is the communicating of the
conductor's own interpretation of the
music and how to do that in an open way
that invites people who
on the communication level I've found
the most fulfilling moments to be when I
am just empty and facilitating a conduit
of energy that comes from the player
goes back to the player or the singer
and that's all about communication the
very first things that we teach with my
students we go into the beat patterns
themselves so this is called the upbeat
and in fact starting and stopping is the
most important thing that the conductor
does how you give that up beat connotes
the tempo and connotes the character and
the dynamic we have one one is simple 1
1 1 when we do a two beat we have one
two one two now for a three pattern we
do one the rebound goes slightly the
other way to hit two travels this way
and then three so while we're making a
triangle this way the rebound is really
important if it needs to be a four
pattern it becomes a little more
complicated so you have one now two is
going to go this way
two three four what's always important
is that the upbeat travels far enough
that it gives room for a good downbeat
if you're stingy here then the musical
choke so it's very hard for conductors
to learn to have a high enough upbeat to
really allow the music to go freely most
students who are studying conducting
have had an experience of beat patterns
if they're in a conservatory environment
and it may take a student several weeks
to be able to do one one one so that
there's a gentle fall and a natural rise
the basic training for tempo is
internalization on the part of the
conductor
how we trained tempo involves the
metronome if we turn the metronome on to
60 which is 60 beats to the minute we
conduct to that we move to that we feel
that we turn the metronome off we step
away get a breath of air come in try to
call back the physical sensation of that
feeling for that tempo conduct conduct
turn the metronome on where we on target
are we too fast are we too slow I will
attempt to conduct 60 beats per minute
let's try 120
here's 48
the fact of the matter is is we become
excited our heart rates raise and then
our perception of tempo can actually run
ahead of us so that a tempo that we
thought was 120 is actually 132 because
our whole physical body is in a faster
tempo to begin with so regulating
mentally to be at the right tempo when
something crazy has gone on in a
performance is a real challenge so
there's a tradition of conducting of
right hand left hand independence mainly
tradition has had that the right hand
since most people are right-handed is
the hand that is going to take
precedence with beat and with entrance
and that the left hand is going to add
more kind of musical elements phrasing
cut offs specific articulations perhaps
specific cues
it's a cue can be done for example here
percussion bang there they are or if
they're over here there it goes or you
might do the cue
percussion there there are other times
when the left hand actually mirrors the
right hand and so you do exactly the
opposite just to create a sense of flow
the other times on the left hand really
does things that are additive
[Applause]
[Music]
if you really can engender right hand
left hand independence you then are able
to show two things at once we have an
exercise which is to do the beat pattern
and then to do for example crescendo
diminuendo
[Music]
I find with almost all of my beginning
students is that we've now figured out
how to do the for pattern now let's do a
crescendo over eight counts it'll look
something like this if the arm will go
with with the beat pattern and of course
you want the arm to be seamlessly
engaged showing something completely
different the pacing and the
independence of the quality of motion is
really one of the great obstacles that
young conductors have to overcome more
than anything the conductor's job is to
create a sense of architecture and the
conductor can only do that if the
conductor understands the form we look
first at the larger structure break that
down into components we look at what's
happening harmonically with those
components in terms of key relationships
throughout we look at how the individual
and smaller components are made up
themselves whether there are what we
call send out a form or a fugue in
another form a conductor needs to be
able to at any moment sing any one of
the parts and that work all the vocal
parts all the instrumental parts you're
doing solfege you're playing at the
piano you're singing you live parts
you're putting it together reassembling
the score in your brain that is what
then empowers the conductor to be open
and in control without being in control
and it's also what empowers the
conductor to go wherever the conductor
is needed in a performance
there's a part of conducting that is
showmanship and the conductor always has
to be careful that that doesn't kind of
take hold and run some people conduct
because they like to stand on a podium
and control other people that's the ego
conductor other people conduct because
they really want to be part of a picture
that's larger than themselves they want
to bring a sense of musicality and
interpretation and they want to
facilitate the hook-up of all the people
who are involved in performing there are
many times where large gestures are
completely appropriate and the music
really reflects that there are times
when a conductor makes large flamboyant
gestures beyond such a scale so that in
the end not one of them means anything
if you've studied your score and examine
the architecture and you know where the
key Peaks are and then you create a
large gesture then you really have
something in the performance we do as
best we can to the zone where we're
completely open completely alive
interacting receiving the information
preparing the scene before the
information happens the beauty of a
performance is that there's no looking
back you're just going forward in that
sense if you've studied the architecture
you can go on an amazing ride
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
that's fun
[Applause]